two young children fighting for their  lives after a crash involving a driver  suspected of being under the influence  it happened near cheyenne and pecos last  night north las vegas police say a  speeding chevy silverado crashed into a  nissan suv that was making a left turn a  third car was also hit  both children and another woman were  inside the suv  they're very preventable we want to make  sure that everybody understands that  they should not drink and drive and  please make sure you're wearing your  seatbelt  the man driving at silverado is under  arrest that driver and his passenger  also being treated at a local hospital  no one in the third car was hurt